hey 42 here Adam was but human he did
not want the Apple for the apples sake
he wanted it only because it was
forbidden wrote Mark Twain and the
reason that Adam wanted the Apple is the
same reason you clicked on this video
now I want you to do something for me do
not think of a white bear for the
remainder of this video oh you've
already failed haven't you the reason
you thought about a white bear was the
exact same reason you clicked on this
video this same instruction was given to
a group of test participants in the 80s
they said to them for the next several
minutes whatever you do don't think
about a white bear of course they all
failed to for the next several minutes
all they could think about was a white
bear no matter how hard they tried not
too many of them attempted to think of
other random scenarios picturing
themselves on holiday for example to try
to divert their minds but a white bear
always found its way into their forts
and before they knew it they were
skydiving in Venezuela with a polar bear
at the end of the study they all
admitted that their attempt to not think
of a white bear were entirely futile why
do our brains have a natural tendency to
think of or do the exact opposite of
what they're told to reverse psychology
can be very powerful
today the middle and upper classes in
Europe eat a diet that consists mainly
of kale chips and hummus but in the 17th
century they ate potatoes that's right
the humble spot today a European staple
was for a long time only eaten by the
upper classes and royalty the lower
classes were superstitious of the potato
they saw it as bland tasteless and many
thought it was poisonous but the upper
echelon of society saw the potential of
the unassuming brown
suitable and a tit plentifully during
the period of the French Revolutionary
Wars the usual food staples in England
which was at the time basically some
variation of a meat pie was in short
supply and England was on the brink of a
famine so the English government took
steps to try to get the English public
to eat more potatoes which were in
plentiful supply they went so far as to
hand out pamphlets entitled hints
respecting the culture and use of
potatoes but no matter how much they
pleaded with the people they just
wouldn't eat potatoes the same struggle
to make potatoes a normal food staple
was happening all across the whole of
Europe eventually it took someone to do
something quite different and not ask
people to eat potatoes but instead to
use reverse psychology
enter Frederick the Great of Prussia the
king of what is now Germany saw great
potential in the potato as a way to
cheaply feed the nation and not have to
rely so heavily on expensive bread so in
1774 he issued an order to his subjects
to start growing potatoes to which they
replied the things have never smelled
nor taste not even the dogs believed
them so what use are they to us so he
concocted a plan he planted a ground
royal field of potatoes and he stationed
Royal Guards to protect the field every
day the local peasants started to grow
suspicious what food could be so
valuable that it requires
round-the-clock guard protection and
just as Frederick had predicted within a
few days the local phoebs
were stealing potatoes from the Royal
plantation and selling them at the local
market for a high price before long the
whole town was eating his royal potatoes
his plan had worked perfectly because he
had made them forbidden and told people
that they can't have the potatoes
suddenly everybody wanted potatoes and
so over the following years this
fondness for potatoes
bread across Europe whether it's
thinking about white bears or eating
potatoes humans love to do what we're
told not to do children are the ultimate
victim of reverse psychology
tella kids a hunger time to eat their
broccoli and they were butch but tell
them that they're not allowed any more
broccoli and suddenly it's their
favorite food but why can our brains be
so easily duped why can we not resist
pushing the red button why do we always
want what we can't have whether it be
our neighbors sports car or wife we even
do the opposite of what we tell
ourselves to do when you're about to
give a speech to a group of people and
you tell yourself to be calm and not to
panic
the complete opposite happens and you
start shaking violently it seems at
times us our brains are just out to get
us why well we'll find out in a minute
but first I just like to take a minute
to Frank Skillshare for supporting me on
this video with skill share you can
learn hundreds of amazing new skills
from the world's leading experts in
their fields Skillshare is an online
learning community with over 16,000
classes in design photo and so much more
anyone can take a class start their next
big project or even teacher class
yourself all at your own pace you can be
a premium member for only ten dollars
per month and you'll get unlimited
access to thousands of amazing classes
the first 500 people to click the link
in the description below will get a
two-month free trial of skill share I
can't recommend this one highly enough
guys it's the most interesting site
you'll ever visit and who knows what you
could learn remember only the first 500
people will get two months free so click
the link in the description now so what
is the secret behind reverse psychology
well it's all because of a thing called
reactance reactance is the concept that
we are all afraid to lose our freedom
and we will do whatever it takes to hang
on to it if our freedom is threatened
for example if someone takes away our
ability to make decision
we react out of fear if someone tells us
that we can't have fast food anymore we
instantly crave fast food because we are
reacting out of fear of losing our
freedom reverse psychology works so well
because when you threaten to take away
somebody's freedom their natural
reaction is to go out of their way to
exercise that freedom and prove to you
that you're unable to take it away just
take a look at faire Romeo and Juliet
when they first met they liked each
other sure but it was only when both
their families forbade them from being
together that they fell crazily in love
and ended up dying for one another it is
one of the most powerful examples of
reverse psychology in literature but the
greatest example of reverse psychology
of all time comes from ancient Chinese
history in the greatest book on war ever
written
the art of war son zhu wrote appear weak
when you are strong and strong when you
are weak during the period of the Three
Kingdoms in China around 200 AD the
country's multiple leaders were at war
and one such leader
chuka lea was known as one of the
greatest Chinese strategists of all time
during the war of the free kingdoms
chuckling was held up in a fort with
only a handful of soldiers when his
enemy Sima Yi learned of his location
and heard that he had so few men
defending his fort Sima Yi set off with
an army of thousands of men to conquer
chuckling and take over his fort but
Leon heard about Yi's campaign before he
arrived
instead of bolting all the doors shorten
putting what few soldiers he had along
the battlements with bows and arrows to
defend the fort till the very last man
and then hide away himself he came up
with a plan involving a magnificent feat
of reverse psychology liang ordered all
the doors and gates of the fort to be
opened up wide he ordered the few
soldiers that he had
to dress up as civilians and to sweep
the grounds inside the fort and the
roads outside using brooms Liang then
sat calmly atop of the fort looking out
at the approaching army and said not was
a word but melodically played his [ __ ]
in an ancient Chinese 7-string plucked
instruments as Yi arrived with his huge
army weapons in hands he was greeted
with open gates peasants cleaning the
streets knots a soldier in sight and a
calm fearless Liang sat atop his empty
fort still playing his instrument
peacefully sensing suspicion yi
instantly fought it was a trap and that
Liang had set up an ambush involving
hiding his soldiers in the surrounding
hills two circle years army from behind
so instead of simply rushing the fort's
Yi quickly ordered his men to retreat
with great haste fearing an imminent
ambush an ambush which of course didn't
exists and so using reverse psychology
Liang had quelled an otherwise deadly
attack Liang's incredible strategy has
since come to be known as the empty fort
strategy and it made its way into the
famous Chinese thirty-six stratagems as
xxxii stratagem from Chinese masters of
war to modern day advertising the power
of reverse psychology is timeless like
this advert for the British Army that
uses reverse psychology to almost make
you feel guilty for not joining the army
and my personal favourite this advert
from a university degree in reverse
psychology but an Amsterdam hotel has
perfected the art of reverse psychology
in advertising by branding itself as the
worst hotel in the world Hans Brinker
budget hotel smack bang in the city
centre of Amsterdam and these by the
very own accord cheap smelly cold not
too clean has absolutely no luxuries and
is generally a dumb awful place to stay
online reviews for the hotel include a
bus shelter offers the same facilities
and what is that smell I demand to know
what that smell is
but instead of trying to improve their
standards they just made these
advertising campaigns instead and this
and this and well would you believe it
it worked since releasing these brutally
honest outs the hotels business is
booming Hans Brinker's 511 beds in 127
rooms are nearly fully occupied all year
round and yes it's still awful reverse
psychology has certainly worked out
favorably for Hans Brinker but not so
much for another well-known advertiser
smoking kills we all know it even
smokers what addiction is a difficult
and emotionally driven problem to
overcome in early 2000 following a
treaty signed at the 2003 World Health
Assembly in Geneva it became the law in
most countries that cigarette and
tobacco packaging had to contain a
health warning some countries adopted
written warnings whilst others contained
highly graphic pictorial warnings in the
following years many world governments
put funds into anti-smoking ads on
national television
such ads are usually highly graphic and
usually end in the protagonist either
developing cancer or erectile
dysfunction the World Health
Organization were pretty pleased with
themselves and believe that this
visceral new advertising would vastly
reduce the number of smokers worldwide
by using fear to make them quit and for
why all the world ignorantly believes
that this strategy was working but what
have we learned that the more times you
tell somebody that they can't or
shouldn't do something the more likely
they are to do it
and sure enough multiple recent studies
have shown that warning labels on
smoking products has absolutely no
effect on smoking or quitting rates
whatsoever moreover a recent study by
experts at Tel Aviv University and New
York University concluded that bizarrely
warning labels on cigarettes no matter
how horrific actually increased
cigarette sales researchers showed
various packets of cigarettes to test
participants some had warning labels on
such as smoking kills and smoking causes
cancer etc and some of the packets had
no warnings at all the participants were
asked which packs they would rather
purchase from the store and the vast
majority of them chose to packets with
warning labels there's something very
interesting going on here this does have
a lot to do with reverse psychology but
there's a lot more to it than that the
researchers also found out that the test
participants believed that the brands
that put warning labels on their
cigarette packages were perceived as
more honest and trustworthy and so in
some strange way the perceived quality
and value of that brand cigarettes when
top in the minds of the participants so
they were more likely to purchase them
reverse psychology isn't just a mental
quirk it's a tool that many successful
people have used under moon net is
Freddie Mercury after Queen recorded
Bohemian Rhapsody a six minute long song
every record company they spoke to said
it was too long to ever be successful
and it would never be played on the
radio so Freddie Mercury gave a copy of
the song to his friend and radio DJ
Kenny Everett as a gift but Freddie
specifically told him to never play it
on air of course ever it did the
complete opposite and played the song on
air over 14 times in a single radio slot
it was very soon number one in the UK
charts and it went on to grace to number
one spot once again in 1991 after
Mercury's death thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video then don't
support this channel on patreon whatever
you do don't hit the subscribe button or
watch any more of my videos and of
course
don't you dare click that link in the
description to be one of only 500 people
to get a 2 month free trial on
Skillshare